all right let's start with America Fest
2022 and Carrie Lakes disgusting rant
which should really serve as a very
scary warning to what is potentially to
come if these people figure out a way to
get more power now fortunately Carrie
Lake lost her Arizona gubernatorial
election and by lost I mean her opponent
Katie Hobbs received more votes and thus
Katie Hobbs will be Governor rather than
Kerry Lake some people seem to think
that's crazy but to me it's logical
Katie Hobbs got more votes so Katie
Hobbs is the governor coming in rather
than Kerry Lake Kerry Lake lost so she
doesn't get to be the governor this is a
complicated concept for many of these
right Wingers this rant and by the way I
don't think this carry Lake stuff Carey
lake is still even though she lost she
ran one election and she lost she's
still being held up as a hero she got
one of the Prime speaking times at this
America Fest event over the weekend but
I think
obviously she's not going to become the
governor so they're going to stop
interviewing at some point I think
she'll maybe end up on Fox news or
something like that she
I I don't even know where to start she
makes an obscene gesture to the media
for being mean to Trump
and one of the funny things is she makes
the gesture to the back of the room
I'm pretty sure it was only right-wing
media covering this thing take a look at
this anybody I know
and these Bastards of the media want to
drag him through the mud
okay
and she's making an obscene gesture
right now
and the crowd is
cheering
yeah she's pointing to the back of the
room
um this is part of the kind of low base
politics that we've covered the American
writing increasingly sliding towards
while we on the left want to talk about
hey you know what dental insurance
should be included in health insurance
why is it separate or is there a way we
can figure out to uh make a transition
off of fossil fuels for home heating
more affordable for everybody these are
the types of questions we're concerned
with this is the stuff that the right is
doing which is increasingly just being
titillating by swearing or making
obscene gestures or making fun of groups
of people usually minority groups of
people that are disadvantaged or
certainly not in positions of power
speaking of which also now very popular
to do sort of a little light anti-trans
rhetoric No Matter What by stating your
pronouns but then saying something
stupid like Carrie Lake says my pronouns
are I won
I know that right now we can identify as
anything we want but I want you to know
I identify as a proud election denying
deplorable
are you with me
yeah
and my pronouns
are
laughs
I just saw another red light go off by
the way
and my pronouns are I one
she lost her opponent got more votes
that's why she's speaking at America
Fest rather than preparing to be the
governor of Arizona so why is this
getting so popular this anti-trans stuff
making fun of pronouns why is it
becoming so popular among Maga trumpists
one reason is that Trump has shown a
tendency to be sort of hostile to trans
rights he's made statements and taken
actions that are obviously hostile to
the trans Community where he ridicules
weight lifters and swimmers and does his
whole routine and talks about teaching
transgender so the suck-ups are going to
follow Trump's lead that's one reason
why this is going on secondly
um Trump supporters have been emboldened
to express similar views and to adopt
the same sentiment it's kind of like the
Kanye anti-Semitism thing which we
talked about at the top of the show it
has an impact and they're feeling
emboldened and more comfortable publicly
saying they believe this stuff there's
also probably a belief to some degree
that if you are aligned with trumpism on
the anti-trans stuff
you're Mo you will be able to mobilize
your base in other ways and
unfortunately it seems to be true to
some degree we saw the anti-trans and
homophobic stuff very very strongly
front and center at CPAC and it did seem
to coalesce and excite people and it
seems like that's more or less what
continues to go on so to the extent that
they seem to get a reaction by doing
this they'll continue the pronoun stuff
even if they don't actually understand a
damn thing about what's going on in the
world of trans and gender as as they
clearly don't
um Carrie Lake also focusing her ire on
Dr fauci and calling him an elf we're
not going to answer to that evil elf Dr
fauci anymore wow
are you really powerful to speak out
against a retiring 80 something year old
Doctor Who spent 50 years helping people
how strong she is
[Applause]
let's lock that man up fast
[Applause]
lock him up we don't need a big sell for
that guy
a small one will do
are they also making fun of fauci
because he's short like I mean we're
getting
America Fest making fun of gay people
trans people
and short people I guess I mean it's all
very very strange and then uh one more
of these clips from Kerry Lake uh
talking about burning Maricopa to the
ground I guess over the election results
that she doesn't like because she lost
they are
right
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do they
have built a house of cards here in
Maricopa County
[Applause]
whoops
[Applause]
I think they're all wondering what I'm
gonna do yeah you're gonna do nothing
Carrie you lost
I'll tell you what I'm Not Just Gonna
Knock that house of cards over
we're gonna Burn It to the Ground
unclear if she's threatening criminality
there but this is at least for now
someone who's considered exciting
a great speaker a great motivator of
whatever Mega trumpism is and she's very
very dangerous now before we move on to
other America Fest stuff I want to look
at one other Kerry Lake event over the
weekend